[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for the first time in his legendary
career lebron james faces elimination
in the first round special bets game
bets
prop bets we're here for all of it so
welcome to the lebron athon
aka the group chat live in the bleacher
report app
presented by fanduel my name is cabbie
richards volunteering her meniscus
for the process is aaron kate dolan and
a man who's not afraid to take a bow
at center court after eliminating your
favorite team that is greg ivory
g-money i know you have something
special for our audience today
what have you got for us yes caddies we
got the hoodies as usual
and i'm actually hold on i don't have
the handy dandy ipad but i have its
little cousin right here it's called the
handy dandy iphone
uh i have it right here i'm gonna get in
the comments and give away
a hoodie why not uh i have bay legend is
in the comments bay legend is in the
comments shout out to you
uh jab jabetsky
duor sebastian jabeski dewards he's
saying lebron
james will go over his point total today
shout out to you you're walking away
with the hoodie
uh but i also have nba jerseys to give
out we're gonna hook you guys up with
125
to pick out whatever jersey you want you
want
i'm gonna give it away later actually
you know what i'll give it away right
now
i'm in the comments giving away 125
to someone who's comedy and i got alexa
lonzo alexa lonzo shout out to you she
gave us the uh
the meme of lebron james and j.r smith
oh there it is right there oh there it
is
you guys see it uh she gave us that meme
uh shout out to you
you are walking away with a jersey
um aaron
aaron aaron i've got three
more to give out tonight what jersey are
you buying
i think i would have to go with the
philadelphia 76ers the cream one i
really wanted that so badly the one that
says philadelphia in cursive but i
didn't never ended up getting it because
we couldn't go into
the game so now that you can finally go
back inside wells fargo i definitely
want to get an embiid cream jersey
so wait g-money are you giving are we
getting jerseys are you spreading the
love to
aaron and i or is it just for the
audience because if you're giving them
to aaron and i
i i you put me on to sunset vibes about
six or seven months ago
so give me the denver nuggets sunset
city edition
jamal murray jersey that red jersey give
me that one
all right and will we get them g-money i
mean yeah
why i don't see why not i don't see why
wouldn't we you know
you don't sound too too sure that we're
going to get what do you mean kathy do
you know what this is right here hold on
check this out what is this what is this
it's american express card buddy
or whatever whenever you want whatever
you want okay
if i had to choose a jerk
if i had to choose a jersey i'm taking
it to the bay man
and i ain't going with with clay or tiff
i ain't going with the light skin
assassins i ain't going with them
big bray drake
yeah the jersey he's wearing right now
is the suit on inside the
uh inside the nba so um at least he's
not a good job
he's doing a great job listen um on the
opposite side of doing a great job the
panic button has been hit
in the city of los angeles causing a
couple of minor earthquakes
both the lakers and the clippers are on
the brink of elimination tonight
there are two game sixes portland and
denver phoenix and
la and after a 30-point land-based thing
in game five we asked you on twitter
will lebron james and the lakers be
eliminated tonight
it's as simple as that game six america
is voting
58 yes they are riding with the sun
cp 3d book hey deandre look we all saw
what happened in game five
and and the homie el capitan hit a big
ticket by calling the blowout
this is just a little eight level right
here 516
bands braun said it after the game they
got their butts kicked
uh it's as simple as that the 30 point
halftime
playoff deficit was the largest of the
bronze career and second largest
in lakers history and this is the first
time
ever for lebron that he's been behind in
a series
after five games in the first round so
uh
let's take a look at the major markets
aaron dolan uh
what do you got for us here what do you
see on the board that you like
so on the fandom sports book the line
open lakers minus three was bet down to
minus
two now back up of course half a point
to minus two and a half and in terms of
that total
both teams have been trending towards
the under the unders hit
4-1 in the last five games of the series
so also just wanted to note though 207
and a half the total that
is currently on the panel sportsbook is
the lowest the line has been set so far
between these two teams in the series
okay so that's the menu aaron just
dropped a bunch of nuggets uh g-money
where is the audience leading
phoenix or la tonight kevin let me get
in the comments and ask him hey
everybody that's watching get in the
comments
tell me whether or not you think lebron
is getting eliminated tonight
tell me also tell me if you think he's
ever winning another championship
because i personally don't think he is
but uh aaron i i don't
that's blasphemy come on bro come on i
mean
unless he's getting a step back another
superstar yeah he's getting up there in
age
he's getting up there still like top but
he's still top
five or top ten let's not let's not
blast theme the king okay
you're not usually a hot take artist g
money and you don't you're not like
on this ridiculousness tip but you know
that braun is a shadow gm
you know that every time you see him
playing another team he's not you know
he's
he's uh he's i don't want to say he's
inspiring
but he has a lot of relationships my
thing is he's just getting up there in
age he's just getting up there in age
that's the only reason but let me talk
to aaron here because
aaron okay i have to know i have to know
is lebron james going out tonight for
good
is the lakers get eliminated tonight
see so i'm so torn on this because last
game i was hyping up lebron i was saying
he's going to be that vintage lebron
he's going to absolutely steal the show
then obviously i was completely wrong
now if ad does play tonight he's
currently a game time decision and if
dennis schroeder remembers he does need
to score last game he had zero points
there is hope for the lakers to force a
game seven but i wouldn't be surprised
if they were not able to do this even on
their home court oddsmakers
obviously agreeing with me as well as
the lakers to win this series right now
it's set on the fanduel sportsbook at
plus 225.
i'll take lebron to be eliminated right
now plus money just given that
we still don't really know the status of
a d for this game
oh is that is that what we're doing
tonight
okay uh lebron the starters
not named lebron james scored 11 points
and gave
five that's not gonna happen in game six
like braun doesn't need to never triple
double tonight
but he's gonna need schroeder kuzma kcp
if he can if he can go
we know that he's got a sore left knee
um andre drummond we need those guys
not we but the lakers need those guys to
at least score in double digits
so on the strength of that and every
dude looking in the mirror tonight
i think that the lakers pushed the
series to seven games they're not gonna
be eliminated tonight
because role players are the key and
they're gonna
they're gonna have a much better
performance than they did in game five
give me lakers in game six
g money which way you lean in is british
brian i can't believe you blasphemed the
king like that saying he's not going to
win another title
in his [ __ ] but anyway tonight g-money
which way are you leading
sons or lakers cabbie
let me get into these comments because
you know the people are here because
they want hoodies
and they also want uh jerseys that i'm
giving away
later i'm giving away more later but
right now i'm in the comments giving
away some hoodies
and i said i see uh i see king of sports
21 says as that boy greg would say on
winners only wednesdays not today lakers
are
not getting eliminated shout out to you
king with sports 21 make sure you tap
back in next wednesday
on winter's only wednesday on be our
betting uh here we go for the chips for
the chip
says boo uh she's a laker hater
hey bad bots bad vibes uh aaron is not a
laker hater but uh
we'll still give you a hoodie i had
lebron winning last game and it did not
go well for me so why would i not be a
little salty and just go with phoenix
aaron
aaron it's it's okay it's the comments
it's okay here
like we will give him a hoodie anyway
and i got one more for you cubby one
more
uh i got not a ronald acuna jr
uh he says if a.d doesn't play
uh goodbye lakers 80 doesn't play
goodbye lakers
and i ended on that comment for a reason
because that's
exactly how i feel i feel like if ad
plays
i feel the lakers are gonna stretch this
series into a seven game series
if 80 does not play the lakers might be
packing their bags and heading to cancun
soon uh but 80s listed as questionable
he's listening that's questionable it is
game six their backs are up against the
wall
so i'm leaning towards him playing and
with that being said i think the lakers
are gonna take this to seven
so you believe that a.d is playing
tonight he's got a groin
injury he's got a brakes he's got
lifted kill his tendoniosus i mean he
lifts it as well
i think the lakers are winning tonight
too i think the wickers are so i don't
even know why bringing those vibes into
into our group chat he still listed his
question
so it's still up in the air so we'll see
we'll see
not since uh the playing game against
the warriors
about two weeks ago have the lakers felt
this much heat
today in the app we asked you how many
points do you think that lebron james
drops tonight the line is high folks
it's 31 and a half
greg what do people have to do to take a
jersey home tonight that is the graphic
braun over under you saw the line
31 and a half cabbie imma tell the
people what they need to do get in the
comments and tell me how many points
lebron james is putting up tonight
i'm going to give away a jersey this
time this is the jersey giveaway this
time so you guys fill those comments up
aaron are you on the over
are you on the under never fun to take
the under but i mean lebron 31 and a
half
absolutely not in this series he's
averaging 22 points inside the staples
center in the series he's only averaging
23.
i want to say that lebron will go off i
know that you guys clearly think that's
that you're taking the lakers tonight
but given this season that nagging ankle
injury and everything
i'm gonna have to take the under on this
one i'm with you i'm taking the end as
well he has the ability to go
off but tonight is about the role
players tres
dennis schroeder markeith morris ben
mclemore
those four guys are looking for new
contracts next year
so you know tonight they need to show up
and they need to make a big difference
so the last time brian even touched 30
points
was on march 18th it was like 10 weeks
ago
he has the capability to get there i
just don't think he's gonna get there
tonight so i'm taking the other he could
get like
27 28 points
but over 31 and a half nah not against
that phoenix defense
so i'll take the under do you mean which
way are you leaning for on with the king
over under 31 and a half
cabbie uh let me get into the comments
let me get into these comments and give
away
a hoodie and a jersey this round and
then i'll give you guys my pick
uh once again guys this is the handy
dandy iphone
handy danny iphone and i'm in the
comments cabbie and
aaron uh i got i got chris
noonion chris union 48 saying
lebron will be eliminated tonight
therefore he i guess he's saying
lebron's not scoring
over uh his point total he's not scoring
over his point though shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie
i also have a
bud smoke smoker bud smoker saying
uh saying lebron james going over he's
rockable lebron james going over
shout out to you uh i'm done in the
comments actually actually i need to
give away a jersey cubby i almost forgot
next person i say you're walking away
with a jersey here we go
brownsfan94 old school lebron james
showing up tonight
threw the gif in there shout out to you
old
uh i mean not old school but brown's fan
94 you were walking away with
cabbie i'll keep this simple and sweet
short sweet and concise i think lebron
james is going to go
under tonight because he's going to be
getting his teammates involved tonight
we've seen this time after time lebron
james and big games
you know we we we want to see him take
over the game scoring all the points
and some games he did some games he did
i can track back trace back to those
warriors games in
2016. brian james was bulk he's balling
but uh tonight cavia i think he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna get his 25 but
he's also going to be
making sure like you said earlier the
other the other players he's the
his teammates you got to get them
involved he's going to be making sure
that they're involved in this
other dudes need to eat for sure bron
can eat but he's got to get other dudes
to the table as well
listen speaking of eating everybody is
crushing these player performance
doubles this week squad legend 4k
management
hit this performance doubles parlay it
was a
it was a chef kiss 85 look at that 100
bucks
wins almost 8 500. that's just beautiful
and it inspired us
to take a look at some performance
doubles of our own these are the props
available for lebron james aaron how
should we think about
betting player performance doubles if
you think lebron is going to put up
30 over 35 are you basically betting
half a game uh for free by sorry are you
betting
uh a free half game uh by adding the win
to your ticket
yeah i mean these are obviously
something that better should take
advantage of because they're great
because they're better value higher odds
than just the straightforward bets in
this particular market that
you just saw on the screen we had the
lakers win plus a player performance of
lebron so
if there is some area that you think
he's going to go off and in terms of
assists or rebounds or something like
that
this is perfect because if you also pair
that with the lakers you're getting
such better odds and obviously we love
anything of plus money
yes yes aaron yes plus money love it
love the plus money love the plus money
cabbies which way
are we in are we one second are we
giving away jerseys or hoodies right
here
oh oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
let me let me think about it cabbie um
we're gonna let's give away some hoodies
let's give away something
all right here uh let's do it yeah but
but wait wait
my i got the last jerseys coming up next
round last jersey's coming up next round
you guys that are in the that are here
get in the comments and uh tell me which
performance double is a lot which which
performance that was a lock aaron
uh which way are you leaning which which
way are you thinking
uh with this performance double so i'm
gonna go lebron double double and the
lakers obviously to win
plus 162. lebron has had 45
double-doubles this season
i also just wanted to mention lebron is
averaging eight assists seven rebounds
in the series so if you want to take
a shot at the ten plus rebounds ten plus
assists and lakers to win obviously go
for it
great value but i think as my lock i'm
gonna go lebron james double double
and the lakers to win that's the shot
i'm taking aaron ten plus assists
i just wish that him and and andre
drummond could just
like just just rim rum homie just like
pick and roll to the rim
get caruso involved find her shooters on
the on the
on the perimeter so i like braun 10 plus
assists
and the lakers win couple those together
get his teammates early on
the way that michael and kobe used to
and then dominate in the fourth quarter
take the game over
we know you're not 100 you've said it
you're not your body's never going to be
100
again we saw it on the shop but so get
your teammates involved early
10 assists if those if his teammates are
making shots
10 assists are definitely within sight
lock that in
uh g money which um performance double
do you like
uh tonight uh for lebron james cabbie
let me get into these comments really
really quick
give away some hoodies because this is
what the people are here for they want
hoodies they want jerseys and i'm here
to give it to him
so i got not zach levine sings the
double double
uh to hit more than three
pointers is a lot oh i guess he said the
double double and to hit more than three
pointers is a lot shout out to you i
don't know if that's a player
performance double but if it is
shout out to you you're walking with me
yeah anyway okay yeah oh yeah he's
walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go uh down to earth says down
to earth says the only one you can take
is lebron
plus three threes he thinks lebron's
about to have a steph curry performance
tonight
shout out to you down to earth you were
walking away with a hoodie uh i got
hitman zaza hitman zaza says lebron
10 plus assist and the win uh i'm gonna
stop right here cabbie
because that's what i'm rocking with
lebron 10 plus assists and a win
we just got done talking about it we
just got done talking about it lebron's
not gonna go over his point total
why because he's gonna get his teammates
involved we're just connecting the dots
here people
we are just connecting the dots here
making it make sense
uh lebron over 10 assists and a win
i like i like that one person's handle
not zach levite because none of us
are zach levine only zach levine exactly
um
folks folks have been out here hitting
all kinds
of long shots on these first basket
parlays
that adrenaline rush from the tip has to
be otherworldly salute to those taking
big swings
like jarrell reyes he turned four
dollars
into almost three thousand that's just
unbelievable
he even has a few doubles sprinkled in
there so we're that's inspired us again
to
build our first basket parlay for
tonight's
doubleheader denver and portland phoenix
and la
let's take a look at the odds for the
first game denver and portland
first basket props these are all juicy
all right sorry this is the second game
phoenix in la and let's take a look at
the first game
uh on tnt tonight with denver and
portland
i like that roko that's a long shot i
don't i don't think i have the guts to
take it but
these odds are so juicy because these
are so hard to hit um
g money is it finally jersey time are we
jumping into these first basket
uh parliament it's jersey
time got one last jersey to give
out get him official song
what was that that's the jersey shore
right aaron aaron knows
aaron knows aaron knows that i live
right by there that's why i know that
a bit crazy
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me who is a lock to hit a first
basket tonight
uh aaron give it to me who do you think
what are you thinking who do you think's
hitting the first basket tonight
well these are awesome the first basket
and like gabby was saying just so juicy
michael porter jr and deandre i feel
like you should go with some of the long
shots these are both at plus 750 just
because
you might as well try to get as much
value as you possibly can for the first
basket tour
can we can we pull up the um can we pull
up portland and denver again
because i i was i was thinking i would
go i was gonna go with a big man i like
roco
down there but i'm i'm gonna play it
safe with christian james mccollum right
there
didn't have a great game in game five
when
damien lillard set the basketball world
on fire with 12 feet pointers but
christian james mccullum just get it
started with a little
nice little you know lane or something
like that so i like cj and in the second
game
again i like my guards dennis schruter i
believe aaron said this earlier in the
game or early in the show
was over nine in the game we know for
sure
he was there we know for sure he needs a
redemption game and that starts tonight
first basket
so give me cj mccollum and dan schroeder
as my parlay
uh g money which players are you
parlaying together for uh the first
basket
cabbie uh
that's a tough one man this is a tough
one uh but i'm gonna go with
damian lillard and uh drummond you meet
drummond
damien little and drummond uh i i simply
think dame he was hot last game i don't
think anything's going to change
the dude was scorching bro it's hot as
an understatement g-money
yeah i just think that he was gonna come
out firing come out absolutely
firing uh and then i also
think uh drummond you talked about it
cavi they need to get him going they
need to get him
in the flow of the offense so uh
i think early on lebron is going to be
looking for him to get him involved so i
think he's going to score the first
basket but guess what
guess what guys i'm giving away a hoodie
and i'm giving away a jersey just
because i feel like
okay so i'm in the comments right now
in the comments uh giving away hoodies
and
a jersey i got meech
norris meech nori's giving us gifts in
the comments shout out to you for
dropping those gift meech nor if you're
walking away with a hoodie
i got uh joe yan is in the comments with
the
game time gift shout out to you joe yang
your walk away with hoodie
ak 47 big blue ayton and lillard both
those teams getting the win too shout
out to you ak-47 you will walk away with
a hoodie
uh cabbie do you think it's time to give
away a jersey or should i give away what
would happen
should i give all your beers absolutely
no let
change get put a smile on somebody's
face tonight i mean they're probably
gonna hit their bets
but why not gift them a jersey as well
my dude
all right we were we were just talking
about jersey we were just talking about
jersey shore we were just talking about
jersey shore
so uh i got somebody in here with the
with the username of jersey please
jersey please
says ride ride lillard to the moon yeah
jersey please
i guess they put one i don't know anyway
jersey please they said
ride lillard to the moon ride lillard to
the moon
hey guess what i'm uh i'm delivering i
was gonna say i'm writing you a t-shirt
but i'm not gonna do that
but anyway i'm gonna give you i'm gonna
give you a jersey
i'm sending you 125 to give you a jersey
but uh
yeah we're also rocking with dame willie
like you saw
i think that he's going to get the first
basket so yeah
shut up perfect perfect punctuation
because uh when it's game time it's game
time listen thank you so much for
joining us
on the group chat presented yes by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the squad knows that braun is in trouble
tonight trouble
trouble trouble salute to j rose get on
fanduel event your favorite first basket
parlay
and come back next thursday for more
hoodies and more jerseys alongside aaron
dolan
and greg ivory my name is kathy richards
thank you for joining us we are leaving
the group chat thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you